et on va plus loin avec Marie Roger
Billaud à directrice africain
International Media Group qui est
aujourd'hui avec douanes de Yaoundé
bonjour Marie Roger
face à vous Cyril Payen grand reporter
ici même à France 24 bonjour Cyril
bonsoir Raphaël combien va-t-il rester
de casque bleu au Mali la MINUS malin
des principaux contenants de maintien de
la paix dans le monde voit en effet un
ses effectifs fondre comme neige au
soleil après le Royaume-Uni après la
Suède l’égypte le Bénin la Côte d'Ivoire
voilà que l'Allemagne à son tour compte
se retirer plutôt que prévu elle d'ici
mai 2024 annonce Berlin en cause comme
souvent comme c'est souvent le cas en
tout cas désormais des tensions avec
Bamako la jante au pouvoir n'accorde
plus d'autorisation nécessaire au drone
de la bundosphère pour effectuer leur
vol de reconnaissance au Sahel hier
c'est à la France que s'en prenait une
nouvelle fois le pouvoir malien en
bannissant les ONG financées par Paris
écouter le présentateur de la télévision
publique malienne
en conséquence le Gouvernement de la
transition décide d'interdire avec effet
immédiat toutes les activités menées par
les ONG opérant au Mali sur financement
ou avec l'appui matérielle ou technique
de la France y compris dans le domaine
humanitaire
est-ce une fuite en avant que recherche
les autorités maliennes Marie Roger
alors il faut quand même on doit la
vérité de dire qu'ils sont ils agissent
par réaction en réaction à l'annonce par
la France d'arrêter de suspendre le
l'aide de développement au Mali donc
c'est une riposte et
ce qu'on voit à un moment donné on sait
rien on se dit mais des deux côtés quand
est-ce que ce jeu de poker va s'arrêter
parce que est-ce qu'il s'arrête est-ce
qu'il se pose la question par moment si
toute cette stratégie toutes ces actions
font avancer les causes ou les intérêts
des uns et les autres est-ce que du côté
de la France le fait d'annoncer que
elle suspendait justement qu'elle
voulait plus
financer le les programmes de
développement le Mali qui
s'élève à peu près sans qu'ils font sans
moins de 100 millions de d'euros par an
est-ce que
ses affaires quand on pense à l'image
l'Afrique de la France en Afrique est-ce
que le sens apaise le sentiment
anti-français et du côté malien c'est
est-ce que
est-ce que le fait de d'arrêter de
d'annoncer en tout cas parce qu'on va
voir ce que ça va donner à la réalité
d'annoncer que toutes ces ONG et qui ont
des actions souvent assez efficaces dans
des domaines d'urgence est-ce que ça
fait avancer aussi la cause des Maliens
c'est-à-dire on ne voit pas qu'il y a
intérêt à aller dans cet escalade de
d'un côté comme de l'autre
ce sont des mesures qui sont
contre-productives elles invoquent sur
il paya ces autorités mallées le fait
effectivement combien de le dire Mario
GIC la France a suspendu son aide au
développement aide publique au
développement à destination du maïs que
c'est une raison valable d'après vous
écoutez en tout cas ça illustre du fait
que à l'instigation des mots qu'on a pu
entendre de la part du du président
français Emmanuel Macron qui est monté
vraiment d'un cran je rappelle que
l'ambassadeur de France à Bamako a été
expulsé manimulatari il y a un an avec
finalement assez peu de réactions de la
part de l'Élysée le signal de France 24
a été coupé là pareil pas grand chose on
voit on assiste en fait à peut-être un
peu tardivement sans doute quand on
regarde ce qui s'est passé avec la le
vieillissement sans doute de l'opération
barkhane donc l'opération française au
Mali le départ des soldats français le
15 août on assiste à une montée en
puissance verbale en tout cas parce que
Marie Roger a parfaitement raison ce
sont des effets d'annonce qui vont être
suivis des faits c'est difficile à dire
ça représente en tout cas sur le côté
français une cinquantaine de ONG
français d'une centaine si on pense à
les zones étrangères qui dépend plus ou
moins ou partiellement de l'aide
française est-ce que directement il va y
avoir un impact pour les 35% de la
population malienne qui dépend de cette
aide qui soit humanitaire qui soit
sanitaire
wood ou de développement ça ça reste à
dire mais c'est vrai que c'est une dette
dégradation c'est une montée en
puissance et on a l'impression par la
voie du président français qui les pré
maintenant en découdre d'ailleurs à
Djerba il y avait des mots très très
durs et en tout cas maintenant il nomme
un chat il parle évidemment de il parle
de de la tentative de déshabillation qui
est orchestrée par par le Poutine et son
bras armé
Wagner et c'est vrai qu'au sein de la
Major français c'était un peu un tabou
on en parlait peu notamment de cette de
cette zone d'influence de cette manière
de bras armé de de de Vladimir Poutine
là on est aussi on nomme un chat un chat
donc en fait il y a vraiment un face à
face mais on est parti il faut le dire
les Français bien plus tard que les
Russes dans cette bataille d'influence
avec sur le Mali il a sous-région en
particulier clairement les Russes en
termes d'influence sont beaucoup
beaucoup d'avance parce qu'ils font avec
très très peu cher énormément de dégâts
il pousse en fait le la France au
divorce avec des pays comme le Mali et
pourquoi pas le Burkina Faso ouais on va
l'évoquer dans un instant le va jusqu'à
accuser la France un Dédé les
djihadistes sont d'ailleurs fournir
jusqu'à présent la moindre preuve quels
sont les raisons en revanche Marie Roger
donnés par Bamako à la défiance 5
exprime cette jeune désormais non plus
seulement vers la France mais en vert
également l'Allemagne puisqu'elle s'en
va pour cause de non survoles du Sahel
de non autorisation donnée à ses avions
c'est drôle en l'occurrence et puis et
puis quel est le motif aussi de la
défiance exprimé envers la Côte d'Ivoire
on a retenu quand même un certain nombre
de militaires ivoirien ce qui a provoqué
vers la décision de de d'Abidjan enfin
yamoussoukran en l'occurrence de quitter
cette
minusma à brève échéance
et bien on a vu depuis le début que
cette jungle militaire joue sur une
seule fibre pratiquement pour se
maintenir au pouvoir c'est flatter le
l'ego nationaliste la fibre nationaliste
des Maliens parce que au quotidien les
problèmes sont énormes ils ont
absolument rien réglé de tout ce qu'ils
avaient promis de faire même la
construction des tas de droits les
élections c'est pas où on en est tout
simple à régler il y a beaucoup de
mécanes mécontentement local en restant
on lit la presse malienne c'est quand
même et la gabegie etc et mais pour eux
c'est un film tant qu'ils arrivent à
dire attaquer la France c'est une cible
facile et une cible populaire mais
pourquoi l'Allemagne pourquoi la Côte
d'Ivoire surtout la Côte d'Ivoire
mais ils se sont un peu enfermés dans
une position
autiste on a le tout le monde et contre
nous et il n'y a pas que la Côte
d'Ivoire la Côte d'Ivoire le Niger et
ceux qui sont à peu près sont un bon
terme seulement avec un autre régime
poutiste lui de Guinée et bon avec les
Togo qui est médiateur mais c'est un
régime qui se replie sur lui-même et qui
qui fait énormément de dégâts et des
causes parce que là la seule chose c'est
à dire quand on engage un combat contre
un adversaire comme la France son seul à
tout le seul à tout du Mali aurait été
d'être d'avoir des alliés par la
sous-région et de tirer dans la dans la
même direction c'est pas du tout ce
qu'il faut c'est une politique qui est
assez aberrante et qui a pour ça les
voilà le seul but qu'on voit de loin
c'est de se maintenir au pouvoir mais
pas parler que du Mali parce que là la
France que je fais la France
la France aussi est entrée dans ce jeu
de cours de récréation parce qu'on dit
en découpe le Mali c'est quoi cette
histoire en découdre pourquoi le Mali
montrer de faire une fixation sur le
Mali pour de vrai pour des raisons qu'on
peut comprendre aussi cette jeune
militaire mais pour pourquoi pas sur le
chat etc et aussi pourquoi prendre des
mesures qui sont défavorables un peu à
l'image de la France urbain c'est c'est
contre-productif je ne sais pas ce que
ça rapporte à la France de faire ce
genre d'annonce du tout c'est un peu
excusez-moi j'ai une autre un autre
exemple c'est comme de interdire de ces
jours une activiste africaine qui
critique beaucoup la France et qui vit
en Suisse se dire c'est la rendu encore
plus populaire donc on ne sait pas trop
comment se prendre des décisions est-ce
qu'on réagit de manière épidermique
carnée une puissance comme la France et
qu'on sache sur le Mali il y a une part
de passionnelle dans la dans la réaction
française Cyril payant tout est
totalement calculé je crois que vous
avez raison passionnel bien sûr et à
l'image de cet émotivité je dirais du
président français que j'ai
personnellement suivi dans des sommets
avant que tout cette on arrive à cet
état de dégradation qui ressemble à une
fuite en avant de de côté d'ailleurs et
Marie Roger a parfaitement raison mais
je crois qu'il y a aussi la guerre en
Ukraine qui joue un rôle important et
que derrière l'attitude de ces jantes
que ça soit Ouagadougou ou à wabamako
pour le citer quelques il y a évidemment
cette influence néfaste en tout cas très
très prégnante de Moscou et Moscou
cherche et je répondais à votre question
sur les pourquoi les Allemands pourquoi
les Alliés cherche à avoir un nouveau
front il a le front est que l'on sait
avec son après l'invasion l'invasion de
l'Ukraine mais de déstabiliser les
inter-européens en biais évidemment
favorisant la France c'est plus facile
c'est l'ancienne puissance coloniale
avec ses relents panafricanistes
évidemment mais c'est aussi ouvrir un
nouveau front et de déstabiliser sur un
front africain facile pas très cher avec
des influenceurs dont on a cité qui sont
très faciles pour mobiliser une petite
minorité mais qu'on entend beaucoup
c'est aussi une manière de stabiliser
une certaine idée de la démocratie de
déstabiliser l'Europe et de déstabiliser
la France donc la Russie n'est jamais
très très loin dans ce paradismes la
France en tout cas pourrait bien se
désengager davantage encore de cette
région le Sahel dans un entretien au JD
le ministre des Armées Sébastien Lecornu
n'écarte pas le départ des forces
spéciales françaises basées au Burkina
Faso
qu'est-ce qui inquiète la France ou qui
peut provoquer ce type de décision au
Burkina Cyril c'est sur certainement une
provocation de la part du ministre des
armées qui répond à de nombreuses
manifestations d'ailleurs l'ambassade de
France par la queue de Quai d'Orsay
aujourd'hui même à demander plus de
protoprotection officiellement aux
autorités burkinabè après donc c'est
manifestations répétées contre des
intérêts français parce qu'on voit bien
que les drapeaux russes sont propagés
beaucoup des drapeaux neufs d'ailleurs
en général donc on peut on peut imaginer
que c'est très très orchestré mais il y
a une menace il y a une inquiétude et on
se pose légitimement la question et
d'ailleurs l'état-major aussi puisqu'on
affirme pas les déclarations de leur
ministres c'est-à-dire qu'il est
possible sans calendrier que l'opération
Seb c'est-à-dire ses forces spéciales
300 forces spéciales à baser au Burkina
Faso qui sont si importantes sachant
qu'on ne les Français ne sont plus au
Mali il y aura il y a beaucoup de
soldats en fait au Mali on le disait son
si importantes notamment dans la zone
des trois frontières avec cette énorme
métastases djihadiste pour le pour les
contrées mais peut-être ce ré-articuler
ailleurs en tout cas c'est vraiment
l'air du temps on est en dans une guerre
une joute verbale très importante qui va
mener où on ne sait où la France Marie
Roger réagit à ses réactions
d'hostilités qu'on vient de le voir
c'est manifestations est-ce qu'elle a
raison de le faire
bien sûr déjà lorsqu'il y a des
manifestations d'austérités pour réagir
mais réagir comment pour réagir
intelligemment il faut comprendre et il
faut dialoguer il faut essayer de régler
problème qui se posent or là on est dans
des attitudes des coups de menton des
bons de toutes les façons les forces
spéciales qui étaient de l'opération
sabre au Burkina
quand on apprend c'est vrai que ils
existaient on entendait parler jusqu'à
quatre ou pas etc mais regardez pas
beaucoup le Burkina parce que la
situation était semblée différente de
celle du Mali mais depuis qu'on voit que
le le Burkina croule sous les attaques
terroristes il y a un nombre de morts
absolument impressionnant on se demande
mais que faisait cette force là et donc
tous ces retraits minusma même la
minusma des Nations Unies qui s'appelle
force multi dimensionnelle de
stabilisation tout ça on se demande à
quoi ça servait et donc le
le départ de toutes ces de ses forces ne
va pas changer la donne c'est seulement
le signal que ça donne se dire voilà on
s'en va on n'est pas content on se
retire etc mais sur le terrain ça va pas
changer grand chose parce que déjà le
premier problème qu'on a évoqué celui de
la coopération il faut savoir déjà que
les les Maliens eux-mêmes envoient près
d'un milliards de d'euros par an en tant
qu'en transfert au Mali contre 100
millions de
public au développement français c'est
toujours ça à prendre mais ça veut dire
les proportions
c'est pour ça que c'est pour eux c'est
c'est plus facile de se séparer
lorsqu'on dit la France s'en va ça va
créer des romans énormes sur le terrain
au Burkina ou ailleurs même s'ils ont
besoin de soutien mais parce qu'on n'a
pas vu les résultats de tout ça on a vu
les les déploiements gigantesques mais
le Burkina par exemple attend toujours
des soutien un peu plus efficaces et
c'est ce qu'ils essayent en tout cas de
mettre en place le Burkina va s'ouvrir
désormais à la Russie et à la milice
Wagner sans doute mais avec les quitte à
contrecarrer ce que vient de dire
Roger avec les résultats faibles que
l'on voit au Mali c'est-à-dire que il y
a une avancée bien évident dans un
rapport d'ailleurs qui a été rendu
public
c'est factuel depuis le départ des
forces françaises et bien il y a une une
propagation djihadiste quel que soit
d'ailleurs les affidés ou les les
allégeances et que on se retrouve
virtuellement j'exagère à peine dans la
situation de 2013 quand les Français
sont intervenus pour sauver sauver
Bamako aujourd'hui il y a des d'un
rapprochement même de la de la capitale
le Burkina Faso n'est pas mieux loti et
d'espérer une troisième voie par Wagner
et la et la voie russe est un petit peu
à mon avis être très très optimiste mais
il y a il y a une grande différence
depuis le départ des des Français ça
c'est indéniable Marie tous les réagir
très important je ne dis pas du tout que
Wagner la solution loin de là je crois
que même les Maliens commencent à s'en
rendre mais je dis seulement que les il
y a une situation sur le terrain qui
attend d'une vraie décision et de la
vraie efficacité c'est pas vrai c'est
parce que j'ai dit et que on avait sabre
on avait parce que on dit depuis que la
France est parti elle n'est pas là pour
maintenir une espèce de statut pour ce
qui est pour combattre
on a dit aussi au moment où la force
barkhane se retirer
il y avait trois quarts du territoire
malien qui était menacé c'est par les
djihadistes c'est-à-dire lorsqu'on fait
une carte au début de l'opération il y a
en 2013 il y avait un petit 1/8 du
territoire qui était menacé ou un
sixième ça dépend des calculs à la fin
de Markham c'était presque tout le pays
donc on peut pas me dire que c'était
beaucoup plus efficace c'est sûr que
avec le retrait il y a une espèce
d'appel d'air c'est sûr mais mais ce
n'est pas une apologie justement c'est
pas une défense de l'efficacité parce
que c'est passé pendant 9 ans merci
Marie Roger très rapidement
une guerre de communication sans doute
que les Français qui ont eu des
résultats tout de même oh non pas
communiqué ou beaucoup trop tard et ce
qui va réussir c'est que les Russes en
tout cas les gens sont le terrain
communiquent eux extrêmement bien via
leurs influenceurs et là cette partie
informationnelle cette guerre
internationale ça c'est clair qu'on est
très très mal engagé du côté français
merci Cyril Payet merci également Marie
Roger Billois c'était ton va plus loin